hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the latest events in the
black clover story
including austin liba's return
and their very first real battle since
they formally met each other and started
training together
i will also talk about the crazy news
that we just got about the black clover
anime
and so much more so let's get into it if
you enjoy
our black clover content and you want us
to keep it going
please leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it really does help
and if you're new to animal pro or maybe
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror finally this
video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
first up i want to quickly talk about
the shocking announcement that the final
episode of the black clover anime will
be airing on march
30th of 2021 official sources have
stated that episode
170 of black clover will be the quote
unquote
final episode but the same sources also
stated that a major black clover
announcement will be made
on that same day since the black clover
anime is currently just getting warmed
up with the spade kingdom war arc this
announcement has led to
massive speculation about whether the
anime has been cancelled for good
or whether it's just going on a break to
give the manga some breathing room
or whether the anime will be going
seasonal like mha
and demon slayer personally i don't like
the sound of that
final episode and i wish that if this
was a break then they would just come
out and say it
the big announcement that's coming on
march 30th might be news about the anime
going seasonal and i certainly hope that
this is the case
but it could also be about a black
clover movie or something along those
lines
i'm guessing that by episode 170 the
anime will be around the place where
yami is kidnapped by xenon
so maybe the rest of the arc including
the big rescue operation
will actually be animated in the form of
a movie
that would be in line with what other
anime like demon slayer and made in
abyss have done
and with how massively successful the
demon slayer movie has been
it was literally the highest grossing
movie in the history of japan
despite the current global health crisis
so finishing up this epic war arc as a
movie
might actually be a good business move
with that said though
i don't want just one movie i want the
anime to continue
so i hope that the anime will get a
proper continuation sometime
in the near future as i said the words
final episode
do make me a bit nervous but i'm trying
to stay positive
please let me know down in the comments
what you think about this news
and what do you think that that big
announcement is going to be
okay now let's get into the chapter we
start off with an explanation for how
the dark triad and morris manage to get
their hands on two
ancient demons i mean ancient demons
don't exactly grow on trees
so i do appreciate the explanation
before this arc we only ever heard of
one of these creatures which was
leaked demon transformation and that one
appeared
hundreds of years earlier so yeah it was
kind of strange to suddenly see
multiple ancient demons popping up in
the spade kingdom
as it turns out at some point in the
distant history of the spade kingdom
there were two people with royal blood
who had incredibly strong magic
these two people were close friends but
at some point their friendship turned
into
hatred and so that hatred eventually led
them to transform
into those giant demons presumably
their rivalry got so bad that they were
willing to use forbidden magic to fight
each other
and ultimately that is what led them to
transform into the ancient
demons however the spade kingdom managed
to seal the two demons away
although we don't know the details on
how they were able to do that
the house grinbery all had been tasked
with guarding these ancient demons
throughout the generations
but after they took the throne by force
the dark triad decided to wake up the
demons and use them against
the clover kingdom one of the demons
remained in the spade kingdom capital so
that it could fight the invading clover
kingdom magic knights and the spade
kingdom resistance
and the other demon was sent to attack
the clover kingdom's royal capital
itself
and honestly this was a very good plan
when you think about it
the clover kingdom sent most of its
strongest magic knights including
captains and vice captains to the spade
kingdom
so now the clover kingdom has to defend
itself from this gigantic
ancient demon without their best mages
wizard king julius is still in the
capital but his
young body can't handle the kind of
power that his adult
body could and so as the ancient demon
rushes towards the clover kingdom
capital
the defense of the city is left up to
the likes of kaiser granvorka
sol kirsch and nozella noel's other two
siblings
among others now i'm not putting these
guys down
okay kaiser is still a magic knight
captain
and these other guys are quite strong
but compared to the likes of mero leona
fugolion yami or
seke they're just not on the same level
and we can't forget who the enemy is
here
this isn't like some dark disciple or
something the first
ancient demon who attacked the clover
kingdom 500 years ago
was taken down by lumiere the first
wizard king
and one of the strongest mages in the
history of the clover kingdom
no one in the capital at this time can
compare to the likes of lumiere
and although julius at full power is one
of the strongest mages in the history of
the kingdom
unfortunately he is nowhere near his
full power at
this time even the combined magic of all
of the available mages at the capital
can't do much to stop the giant demon
the best they can do is
alter the direction of his attacks and
slow him down a bit
even damnatio kira gets involved and he
tries to use his scale magic to
neutralize
some of the demon's magic but the demon
just has
too much magic and kira's scales don't
have enough of an effect to make a
difference
then out of nowhere julius appears
on the scene and shockingly he is an
adult again
julius somehow managed to age his body
10 years so that he could be
in his stronger adult form this is only
temporary and he still isn't at full
power
but julius believes that if he works
together with kira he might be
able to stop the demon his grimoire also
appears to have restored itself to some
extent
it is more than just a single page now
and so for a moment
it looks like julius might actually make
a real impact
in this fight but despite julius's best
efforts
his time quickly runs out and he reverts
back to his young
form so julius can't really do anything
to the demon
and after that things look really bad
for the capital as everyone comes to the
conclusion that the ancient demon is
pretty much
unstoppable the citizens of the capital
brace themselves for the worst as the
demon prepares
a massive attack but then right
in the nick of time the anti-magic bros
make their appearance
asta and chibi liebe arrive on the scene
and attack the giant demon they are
attempting to neutralize his attack
as they prepare to use their own brand
new form
devil union or devil unite and
that is how this chapter ends as in
literally right before we actually get
to see asta's new
devil union form yup
yup thanks tabata but even though we got
teased with the new form yet again i
really liked
this chapter and i'm super excited for
the next one
it seems like we will finally get to see
astan leave his new form in the next
chapter so i'm definitely looking
forward to it
hopefully the next chapter won't switch
focus to like noel and the elves or
something and then make us wait even
longer
but we'll have to wait and see all in
all the events that are currently
taking place in the clover kingdom
capital are historic
and austin liebe are about to change
everything
including how the rest of the kingdom
looks at them and at
devil magic if austa manages to defeat
the ancient
demon and save the royal capital he will
become
a hero and if a commoner who was born
without magic
can succeed where nobles and royals and
even the wizard king
failed then no one can deny that asta is
indeed
a true hero the other citizens may have
been suspicious of someone using devil
magic
up to this point but they can't argue
with results
if asta can save all of their lives
right before their eyes they can't
possibly think that he is evil
otherwise why would he risk his own life
to save the royal capital
the hatred for asta and the
discrimination that has been hurled his
way
may now finally end although
realistically
some individuals like damnatio kira and
augustus will probably still hate him
they will be jealous that a commoner did
something that they couldn't
and that will challenge their entire
worldview since they firmly believe that
royals are
always superior to commoners no
exceptions
that is obviously not true and asta is
living proof of that
but just like in the real world there is
no end to some people's
ignorance however i do hope that most of
the clover kingdom's citizens
will now be able to see the truth about
asta who is without a doubt
a hero and a good wholesome boy with
all of that said though i have no idea
why the mages
in the capital didn't just ask the
strongest mage of all
my boy augustus kira clover to kick the
ancient demon's ass with his epic and
overpowered
light magic i mean just imagine the
absolute monarch of divine brilliance
taking on this puny ancient demon
but who knows maybe the great augustus
is just saving his strength and he will
be the one who strikes the final blow
once osta softens the demon up a little
but let me know what you guys think did
you like this chapter as much as i did
and what do you think that austen
libra's new form is going to look like
also do you think that julius will now
be able to age himself
back to his adult form on a regular
basis
or was this a one-time thing finally
do you think that asta is going to take
the ancient demon out
all on his own or is it going to be more
complicated than that
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black lover content right
here on the channel
don't forget to leave a like it really
does help and if you're new here or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
hitting that
bell and then selecting the option that
says all i know it's annoying it's an
extra step
but if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twigo himself and i
can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
liam thompson
algital dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor
otaku spidey life canal big buddhist and
tungsten tarkis
finally thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz anatoly
kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica califond
rathu in deora alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games deadly saint matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you